the strike action that we've put on the
pressure that's been put on the
companies there's been an awful lot of
pressure put on the companies in the
government in the last week or so
in Parliament the regional mayors
have been on through the Scottish
government has been on to uh the
secretary of state so there's a general
consensus that the railway is in a
crisis which isn't all to do with the
strikes I think the strikes are a minor
part of that it's the competence of the
government and the competence of the
train operators
so people were wanting to put a bit of
energy behind that and get a solution to
this element of the crisis which is the
uh the strikes and the industrial
dispute but I don't think there'll be a
real answer until they work out the way
the management of the Railway is
structured and for us that means public
ownership
but for them it will probably mean
continuing with what they've got so
we'll have to see how that works out
and this idea to the layperson of the
government giving them a mandate that
basically means that you know at the
moment you feel like you have been able
to even deal with a 10 company well we
haven't been able to because we haven't
had a uh a structure in which we
negotiate they've never put an offer on
the table
so hopefully either today or over the
weekend they'll start to do that and
then we'll have to take that back to the
union see what see what they come up
with I've got a feeling it might be
quite
modest might be the polite word the
poultry might be another word so we'll
have to see how that goes in the next
few days
starting at half past 10 here but it
feels like things are moving along
though well they're definitely moving
it's definitely different as it was over
the last six months there's no doubt
about that but we've got to find out
whether it's meaningful whether it's
just uh you know window dressing as they
say
and how do you feel posted to meeting
with Mark Harper and with various sort
of um approaches in the media
the line there's no doubt about that the
line compared to chefs we had the short
period where there was another person
which didn't really count because that
government fell uh it's definitely a
different approach but it's got to have
some meaning they're still gonna keep an
extremely tight control over the purse
drinks
and whether our members will be able to
accept what they offer not
forgetting that there's pay is only an
element it's what's going to happen to
their jobs and what's going to happen to
their working practices and their
conditions which are really important on
the railway people work 24 7 all through
the year a heavy shift pattern on social
hours and all the rest of it so that's a
vitally important aspect for them
about what happens with their jobs in
the future so you can't divorce one
element from the other and that's the
important part so how seriously do you
think the government are taking these
strikes then
oh they're definitely taking them
seriously but you've got the other you
know there's an awful lot going on in
society and in the economy at the minute
where you've got the uh the Health
Service the education unions
uh fire brigade anyone you want to name
mind yourself is going to be involved in
industrial action soon so
um they've got a lot on their plate